Let's predict the euros in 60 seconds
so Germany are the hosts
and they'll definitely advance at A.
Group A then
I'm gonna set Hungary through alongside them.
Switzerland are always good,
but they're gonna be my dark horses.
Tournament for the group of death.
That have Croatia going through along with Spain.
That means Italy will go out.
Now England might finally be my
actual favorite to win the tournament,
so I'm gonna put them through alongside Serbia.
Groups D, E, and F still have one spot to fill
based on one team from each of these three pots,
but if I'm honest,
I'm not too inspired by any of the teams.
I think Poland and Ukraine will go through,
and then I hope Georgia qualifies as well.
Group D probably won't be affected too much by this.
I mean France and the Netherlands,
two favorites to win the tournament.
But this is where teams from Path A would be played.
Scenes from Path B would join. Group E,
which respectfully
is one of the weaker groups on paper,
so it could definitely be affected.
But in the meantime
I'll pick Belgium and Slovakia.
That leaves Group F,
which has Portugal,
Turkey, the Czech Republic in the winners of Path C.
Turkey has let me down recently,
so I'm gonna pick Portugal and the Czech Republic.
Let me know your group predictions!
But this leaves these teams going through
and these teams exiting early.